thanks to curiositystream for supporting
this episode go to curiositystream.com
microcosmos to start streaming thousands
of documentaries and for a special offer
that helps support our show
[Music]
our world is made up of invisible
highways they intersect and divert and
congest taking organisms on short trips
and long voyages alike in a flurry of
activity
now we may not be able to see all of
those highways laid out the way
commuters might see long stretches of
concrete stacked on each other but we
can start to see their outlines in the
lives that are traced upon those roads
the micro cosmos is no exception in fact
it is where all those journeys begin
[Music]
when anthony von levenhook made his
first observations of microbes he was
captivated by those primitive paths even
though he didn't know what he was
observing
he didn't even know what creatures he
was observing he wrote the motion of
most of these anti-molecules in the
water was so swift and so various
upwards downwards and round about that
it was wonderful to see
leenhook hired a draftsman to help draw
what he observed and sharing his
employers delight the draftsman
reportedly exclaimed oh that one could
ever depict so wonderful emotion
and probably did it in dutch but you get
the idea
the turn of the 18th century was not a
particularly great time for video but
fortunately times have changed and now
we have ways to depict so wonderful
emotion
and that means we can share things like
this
a band of bacteria or really more like a
cylinder of thousands of bacteria that
have gathered for some unseeable reason
that must be important to them we think
though we can't quite be sure that the
culprit is oxygen
james our master of microscopes kept the
slides in a humidity chamber that was
low in oxygen an environment that was
well suited for these bacteria when he
took the slide out to check it under the
microscope oxygen began to seep in from
the sides and while many organisms love
oxygen these bacteria do not and with
their habitat being slowly encroached
upon by the gas the bacteria gathered in
the middle of the slide where the oxygen
is lower
if you take a quick glance the band of
bacteria seems pretty orderly but it
just takes a few more seconds to see
that it is made up of chaos bacteria
that are swimming and wiggling around in
what seem like a completely undirected
fashion except of course
it is directed they are navigating
inside an invisible road
shaped by oxygen
in 1882 the scientist theodore wilhelm
engelmann used a microscope designed by
carl zeiss himself to watch algae as
they photosynthesized
but it wasn't just the algae he was
interested in
engelmann also watched as oxygen loving
bacteria congregated to the areas where
algae lay
seeking out the oxygen byproduct of
their neighbor's photosynthetic activity
engelmann's work provided descriptions
of bacteria changing their behavior
around invisible chemicals
but it would take a contemporary of his
and then several decades of waiting for
scientists to figure out the mechanisms
underlying those changes
his contemporary was named wilhelm
pfeffer and he designed an experiment
using a thin capillary tube filled with
chemical solutions to study how bacteria
gathered first to the tube and then
inside of it after fever the field
becomes quieter until the middle of the
20th century when a scientist named
julius alder began searching for his
next research project the one he would
pursue after studying butterflies in
college and a rat liver mitochondria in
grad school it was 1957 and he just
happened to be going through a library
filled with old scientific journals
where he found pfeffer's publications
and what he read would end up inspiring
decades of his work as well as the work
of his students and colleagues to
decipher the chemical and biological
language that bacteria were using to
navigate the world around them
for instance he established that
bacteria are able to detect molecules
around them without actually consuming
those molecules using receptors at their
surface to process and respond
one student mel de pemphilus used an
electron microscope to capture images of
the bacteria's motor called the flagella
later he would say i was so excited i
could not take photos but kept thinking
my god i am the first person to see this
a tiny peek behind the curtain there is
a note on the script here and james our
master of microscopes has made a comment
and he says
aha this happens to me all the time
what a joyous feeling that must be but
also look all of us together
are seeing that thing that mel de
pemphilus first saw all those decades
ago and it is no less remarkable for
having been seen by others anyway
over time what became apparent is that
the flagella doesn't just move bacteria
because swimming in the microcosm is
kind of difficult when you're small the
water is thick like honey but what the
bacteria's combination of flagella and
receptors do is let the organism move
randomly
but also purposefully
the systems can vary among different
bacteria they do after all have
different needs from their environments
but so much of what we know comes from
studies of e coli and in e coli the
movement of the flagella dictates
whether the organism will tumble around
or propel forward now why would an
organism want to tumble what does
randomly turning about do well for you
and i tumbling is probably at best not
useful at worst disorienting but for
bacteria it's a way to get reoriented
allowing them to point in different
directions until they find the right way
forward and to determine what the right
way is
they measure gradients looking for
changes in the amount of those chemicals
they either want to get closer to or
further away from
when those changes point to something
good the bacteria propels onward and
when they point to something bad it
tumbles
they can do this incredibly fast capable
of speeds that are several hundred body
lengths per second it's like sprinting
home in the dark guided only by the
familiar changes in the streets around
you but it is enough to have helped
these bacteria survive this world and
its many many challenges for billions of
years of course it also means that other
organisms have inherited those
mechanisms too like these ciliates drawn
as they are to their bacterial prey
through an invisible connection whether
or not they knew that's what drew them
there in the first place
because even when the roads are unseen
and even when we may not know where
we're going we can surely figure out
what to do
when we get there
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
this episode was brought to you by
curiositystream it's a subscription
streaming service that offers thousands
of documentaries and non-fiction tv
shows from some of the world's best
filmmakers including award-winning
exclusives and originals they cover
topics like history nature science food
technology travel and more there you can
watch the documentaries like never home
alone where they explore the unseen
wildlife that lives in all the nooks and
crannies of your home and take a
microscopic journey through your food
cabinets and shower heads you can stream
curiosity streams library including
their collections of curated programs
hand-picked by their experts to any
device for viewing anytime anywhere and
if you go to curiositystream.com
microcosmos and use the code microcosmos
to sign up it will only cost you 14.99
for an entire year
all the people on the screen right now
they are folks that moved through the
wondrous gradients of knowledge and
algorithmic suggestions to find our
content and then love it enough that
they wanted to support it so that we can
keep making it and keep making it better
they are our patrons on patreon you can
become one of them by going to
patreon.com
journey2micro if you would like to see
more from our master of microscopes
james weiss you can check out jam and
germs on instagram or you can see him in
emily grassley's new video where the two
of them discuss microscopy and emily
even painted a painting inspired by some
of the tardigrades you have seen on this
very channel and you can go check that
out at our link in the description and
if you want to see more from us hey
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
you